hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
maybe you've known someone who was in
need of an organ transplant finding a
donor isn't easy nor is it quick in a
situation where time is of the essence
the wait can be painful that is if
you're even lucky to get an organ
donated at all while soon this may
become a thing of the past
researchers have just made a
breakthrough by 3d printing a heart from
real human cells this is one step closer
to a future where 3d organs can be
printed on demand in this video we'll
take a look
since the 1800s scientists have
developed vaccines and medicines by
growing cells in glass petri dishes it
was instrumental in advancing biological
science for the past few centuries in
recent years with the advent of 3d
printing the 2d petri dish has now been
upgraded to another dimension a
revolution has started to develop
lab-grown organs for transplants
researchers at Israel's tel aviv
university have just successfully 3d
printed a heart made from real human
cells previously this was only achieved
with non organic materials such as
silicon yad incredible potential
breakthrough in making organs in a lab
Israeli researchers have printed a 3d
heart to complete with muscle and blood
vessels explain that the cells had made
the heart came from a donors fat tissue
which were then transformed into
embryonic stem cells and then
differentiated into the various cell
types in the heart the heart is small
only about the size of a rabbit's heart
however researchers were able to create
chambers and veins which nobody had
previously achieved before the
researchers envision creating 3d printed
hearts suitable for human transplants
and also patches which can regenerate
defective tissue professor Tolliver he
led the project stated quote this was
the first time anyone anywhere has
successfully engineered and printed an
entire heart replete with cells blood
vessels ventricles and chambers end
quote
with that being said some obstacles
still stand in the way while the cells
can contract they do not possess the
ability to pump which is the researchers
next objective but there are still many
advantages in comparison to traditional
organ transplants to be optimistic about
normally in organ transplants the body
may reject an incoming organ this is due
to the immune system sensing antigens in
the cells of the organ which did not
match the rest of the body cells for
kidneys about 25% of transplant patients
experience an episode of severe
rejection in the first year of the
transplant and for heart transplants
that number rises to 40% but this 3d
printed heart uses human tissue as the
bio-ink here's how it works a sample of
cells can be taken from the patient and
a 3d organ can be printed
personal hydrogel made from their own
cells this potentially resolves
rejection issues this isn't the first
time researchers have printed a heart in
2017 scientists and Zurich Switzerland
3d printed an artificial heart but
instead of using human tissue they were
only able to achieve the feed using soft
flexible silicon material the heart was
able to push and pull water through
intricate chambers at a rate of 80 beats
per minute however it was only able to
pump for 3,000 beats in a row or
approximately half an hour
the Zurich heart was able to achieve a
pump flow of 2.2 liters per minute this
is about two to three times less than
the human heart still far from what's
required to keep a human alive but not
bad for a replica apart from the
application of building replacement
organs 3d printing is being used to
develop new medicines for example what
if rather than being given a
one-size-fits-all medication doctors and
scientists can model your illness and
apply the right exact procedure or
medicine for your case by building
tumours and labs using 3d printing
researchers are attempting to do just
that a team at McMaster University in
Canada have developed a rapid magnetic
3d bioprinting system which can build a
replica of a cancerous tumour in as
little as six hours the idea is then to
test different drugs and treatments
changing the dosage and frequency to see
which one works best then after the lab
testing the patient would be given a
tailor-made medication program this
could decrease side-effects and more
importantly increase the chances of
survival for the patient so this recent
breakthrough of 3d printing a heart with
real human cells foreshadows a future
where on-demand organs are available
without waiting lists according to some
estimates this reality could be less
than a decade away so all of this raises
some interesting questions for human
life how much longer could we extend our
lives if we easily could replace body
parts would most people want to do that
and what about the price of a new heart
will everyone be able to afford it at
first
predictably such technology might only
be available to the rich but in the
future prices may come down far enough
so that the technology could be cheap
and routine and after this what comes
next
high capacity lungs that can provide
more efficiently or heart-attack proof
hearts that are resistant to failure the
future of biotech is an interesting one
as we move from making the best cars
phones and computers perhaps the next
big revolution will be the upgrading of
our bodies so what's your opinion in
such a future do you think that it will
prevent early deaths and suffering or
does this kind of thing bother you and
should we let nature take its course let
me know in the comments section below
I'm interested to know your thoughts
these 3d printing developments are all
very interesting for me I did my
university thesis on 3d printing just
before it exploded into the commercial
space so for me to see the progress and
diversity of its applications in such a
short amount of time has been
mind-blowing anyway that just about
wraps it up for this video thanks for
watching just a bit of housekeeping
quickly late last week are supposed to
release a huge video probably the
biggest video I've done in about seven
years but I'm still waiting on a
licensing agreement from TED talks the
video is going to be a documentary
format like the theranos 4 yet so
hopefully I'll be able to release that
soon but this video was just something
in the meantime while you wait and
lastly don't forget to follow me on
Instagram because I've been posting
there a bit more regularly lately and
that's it thanks for watching this has
been - go you've been watching cold
fusion feel free to subscribe if you
just stumbled across this channel and
I'll catch you again soon for the next
video
cheers guys have a good one
[Music]